Speaker 1: Andrew Yang was interviewed on
CNN about his new third party, the forward
party.
It really went very, very poorly for Andrew
Yang.
And I want to kind of make clear as we get
into these clips, I like Andrew Yang on a
personal level.
He's been a guest on this program many times.
I was interviewing Andrew Yang before almost
anybody else.
It might have been Sam Harris who interviewed
Yang before I did as far as national shows,
but we were early to talk to Andrew Yang.
Universal basic income, etc.
I like the guy.
This interview was a disaster.
Now people who emailed me had two different
points of view.
Some, like me, believe that this interview
was a complete and total disaster because
Andrew Yang continues to just not explain
what are the policies of the forward party.
Others felt that Jim Acosta, the interviewer,
bullied Andrew Yang and did not treat him
well.
I just don't see that Andrew Yang in the forward
party keeps saying we're not left or right
but forward, and we take the common sense
consensus view on all of these divisive issues.
Right.
But you got to explain what the position is.
And you can't just be like, well, anything
goes here because then you're not really a
party.
I believe Jim Acosta did a good job in this
interview.
Let's take a look at some clips.
I think this is very bad for Andrew Yang.
And as I've said before, to me, the Democratic
Party is too centrist.
So when I think of a third party, which I
love, I want third parties.
We need more than two parties.
And we need to figure out the right way to
properly bolster and inject third parties
into the national dialog.
I want something to the left of the Democratic
Party.
Andrew Yang started the forward party with
some Republicans and it looks like they're
basically trying to place it between the Democratic
and Republican parties where there is relatively
little space, by the way, and it just it's
not working for me.
Let's take a listen to the first part of this.
Speaker 2: Interview on both sides.
You're going to have to come up with policy.
Speaker 3: Results, right?
But is it a better system?
Speaker 2: Yeah, but Andrew, you're going
to have to have policy positions at some point.
How does the forward party feel about Roe
versus Wade should have been overturned?
Speaker 3: Well, I personally think that women's
reproductive rights are fundamental human
rights.
But the forward party has not left or right,
but forward stands on even the most divisive
and contentious issue.
Speaker 2: What does that mean?
Yeah.
Speaker 1: What what does that mean?
I mean, that that really doesn't make any
sense.
His personal view is not really the issue.
You have a party here, and if the idea is,
well, rabid, anti-choicers are welcome as
well as anybody else.
But we're going to take a consensus view.
Does that make any sense?
And what is the consensus view?
You've got to explain it.
Speaker 2: To take a position on something.
You don't take a position on something.
You can't just say, well, you know, this is
a hot button issue, so I'm not going to take
a position on you.
You know, you want to run the country, you're
going to have to make some hard decisions.
Andrew.
Speaker 3: Again, the forward party is about
that common sense consensus majority view,
which is very clear on abortion.
Speaker 2: It's not about guns.
Speaker 1: Right now, Andrew Yang is correct.
There's a very clear consensus view on abortion
by a higher percentage than at any point during
the Roe v Wade era.
Americans believe abortion should be legal
in most cases.
That's the common sense consensus view.
But can he not say that because the forward
party is also filled with as many or even
more Republicans than Democrats?
I don't know.
But this isn't really doing it for me.
Speaker 2: What about assault weapons?
Speaker 3: It's actually clear on just about
every issue under the sun.
Should 18 year olds we should go by?
The teens should because of the nature of
our system.
Speaker 2: Should 18 year olds be able to
buy 15?
Speaker 3: Again, the common sense consensus
majority is that there should be some rules
around background checks and access to firearms.
But we're not getting any of these things,
Jim, because the two party system does not
need to deliver.
Speaker 2: It is sound like you're taking
any of the hard positions.
It sounds like you're.
Speaker 3: In.
Speaker 2: Power.
It sounds like you're sort of a fill in the
blank part of, you know, if if somebody wants
a party with no clear policy positions, you're.
But unfortunately, in the real world.
In the real world, you have to take a position
on something.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: And this was kind of an issue when
I interviewed Andrew Yang about the forward
party.
And I said, well, he said everybody's welcome
as long as they believe in two things about
third parties.
And I asked him, Well, so are white nationalists.
Welcome.
And he said, yes, as long as they believe
in those couple of things that imploded.
And later on Twitter, he had to backtrack
and say, actually, the white nationalists
aren't welcome.
I'm just not really getting this.
I want third parties.
I want a lot of the things that Andrew Yang
says he wants as well.
But I'm not clear that we're getting it through
the forward party.
Here's another clip where he was asked about
his kind of unusual tweet about the Mar a
Lago search warrant.
And again, just everything about the answers
is kind of strange.
Speaker 2: Ironic presidential candidate Andrew
Yang.
He recently helped form a new political party
called Forward alongside two former Republican
officials.
We Should Know for it also happens to be the
title of his recent book.
Andrew, thanks very much for joining us.
Can I ask you about something that you tweeted
about the FBI search at Mar a Lago?
You wrote, It looks increasingly like the
FBI raid was to find mishandled classified
documents and not some other DOJ investigation,
which was my first thought.
Mishandling documents doesn't seem like raid
material.
It does, however, seem like excellent campaign
material for Trump.
And I have to ask you.
It sounds like you're you're letting Trump
off the hook here.
Taking top secret documents to your mansion
is okay with you.
Are you giving Trump a pass?
Speaker 3: Well, thanks, Jim, is a very disturbing
report you just got from Donie.
And the fact is extremism is on the rise throughout
the country.
It's one reason why we think the forward party
is so vital, because we think there needs
to be a broad, positive, unifying third party
movement.
But I'm for anything that enhances national
security and the rule of law.
And our hope is that as the attorney general.
Speaker 1: I'm for anything that enhances
national security.
I mean, isn't that a cop out like he's he's
basically saying if what happened at Mar a
Lago enhances national security, then I'm
for it.
But if it isn't, I'm against the like it's
a mishmash.
Speaker 3: And the DOJ dig in that the American
people get a lot of the answer is that many
of us are eagerly anticipating.
Speaker 2: All right.
But are you saying that I don't think you
answered my question.
Are you saying that the attorney general had
political motivations with this search at
all?
Speaker 3: I trust that that all of the DOJ
employees and particularly the FBI agents
are faithful public servants discharging their
their duty.
And it it it hurts us all that people are
singling out individuals in the way that Donald
described it.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So I guess he's against FBI agents
being violently targeted.
One last clip.
And then I'll give you my thoughts on something.
Speaker 3: Oh, we're for the common sense
consensus view on guns, abortion, climate
change.
But we're not getting a.
Speaker 1: What are those views.
Speaker 3: And what are those positions?
And these those things do I mean, those are
just sort.
Speaker 2: Of fuzzy, but those are modulus.
These like you came up with something in a
focus group, you know, common sense, you know,
middle of the ground.
That sounds wonderful.
That sounds great.
But at the end of the day, don't you have
to take a position on something?
Speaker 3: All.
The great thing is the American people know
where we want the country to go and what we
know.
Speaker 1: I don't know that that's true.
Speaker 3: That we need a more dynamic, truly
representative system than we're getting right
now, which is why the forward party is growing
so quickly.
Tens of thousands of Americans have signed
up in all 50 states.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't know.
I mean, tens of thousands.
It doesn't actually sound like very much in
a country of 331 million.
So I don't know what to tell you.
Guys like this isn't feeling like the electric
injection of a third party.
And in my mind, it's just sort of like, okay,
I know where the Democratic Party stands and
I know where the Republican Party stands.
And I know that although I'm not a Democrat
or a Republican, I'm mostly voting for Democrats
because they're closer to where I stand.
If I'm going to consider the forward party,
I need to know what is their policy position
on guns, on abortion, on taxation, and to
say that it's the common sense consensus view.
It's not enough for me to say This is the
movement for me.
If I'm missing something, if I'm being too
hard on Andrew Yang, let me know.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Also, a reminder, Wednesday, August 31st,
we will be doing a members only townhall where
I will field questions for a period of time
from our members.
It will be at 6 p.m. Eastern, 3 p.m. Pacific,
and you can get exclusive access to the member
only town hall simply by getting a membership
at join Packman dot com quick break right
back after this.